to women because they'll say your body
count doesn't matter and you're giving
young and this is what really bothers me
about feminism is i don't like lying to
women you're giving young impressionable
women the wrong information we're saying
sleep with whoever you want do whatever
you want and they might make decisions
that they can't not they can't take back
and it will damage their future
relationships i mean if a girl is a
virgin she has an 80 chance of being
being happily married after 10 years if
she sleeps with more than five people
that drops to 25 percent
is that a stat yes
they surveyed women so that that's why
it's like around five six that you see a
really significant drop
and like the thing is feminism keeps
pushing things like slut-shaming where
men aren't allowed to have standards and
i just don't get with that why are we
allowed to ask all of these things of
men but men can't ask anything of us and
the things that men ask really aren't
that hard
it's it's don't sleep with too many guys
don't get too fat